Verteidigungsminister Treffen im
niederösterreichischen Krems die ceedc
die Central European defence Corporation
ist die Zusammenarbeit zwischen
mitteleuropäischen und westbalkanstaaten
im Punkto Sicherheit in Zeiten des
Krieges in der Ukraine gewinnt diese
Konferenz an Gewicht ich glaube absolut
ja es darf eben nicht außer Acht
gelassen werden dass das nicht der
einzige der einzige Konflikte wir haben
am Westbalkan nach wie vor eine
Instabilität des notwendig macht hier
noch mehr auch an Unterstützung zu geben
und das ist umso wichtiger Seite eben im
Februar dieses Jahres
vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen stehen
ebenso auf dem Programm wie jede Menge
bilaterale Gespräche ein gemeinsames
Abendessen auf einem Weingut soll die
Verteidigungsminister der teilnehmenden
Staaten einander näher bringen
deine abschließenden Pressekonferenz
betont Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner die Unterstützung für die
westbalkanstaaten in diesem unsicheren
Zeiten ich glaube in dieser Kooperation
geht es darum auch wieder neue Projekte
zu entwickeln und das wird sich ja unter
der tschechischen Präsidentschaft mit
Sicherheit auch tun das ist ein Prozess
der sich einfach entwickelt da gibt's
kein Ende sondern einen immer weiter
gemeinsam vorangehen mit einem Ziel
Sicherheit der in Europa und Stabilität
in Europa zu zeigen
[Applaus]